I should mention people should listen to
Andrew huberman who recently talked
about
um alcohol he has an amazing podcast
Andrew humor is a neuroscientist from
Stanford a good friend of mine cool and
he he's like a human encyclopedia about
all health related wisdom so it does a
podcast you you would love it I would
love that no no no no no oh you don't
know Andrew huberman okay listen you
listen to to Andrew he's called humor
and Lab podcast this is your assignment
just listen to one okay I guarantee you
this will be a thing where you say Lex
this is the greatest human I've ever
discovered so oh my God because I
vony of kind of kind of health and
wellness and I'm learning lots and I'm
trying to like build these
I guess Atomic habits around just being
healthy
um so I yeah I'm definitely gonna do
this I'm gonna his whole thing this is
this is this is this is great uh he's a
legit scientist like
um really well published but in his
podcast
what he does he's not he's not talking
about his own work he's like a human
Encyclopedia of papers and so he his
whole thing is he takes the topic and in
a very fast you mentioned Atomic Habits
Like very clear way summarizes the
research
in a way that leads to Protocols of what
you should do he's really big on like I
love that not like this is what the
science says but like this is literally
what you should be doing according to
the side so like he's really big and
there's a lot of recommendations he does
uh which several of them of them I
definitely don't do like
get sunlight
um as soon as possible from waking up
and like for prolonged periods okay
that's a really big one and he's there's
a lot of science behind that one there's
there's a bunch of stuff
you're gonna and you're gonna be like
Lex this is uh this is my new favorite
person I guarantee it and if you guys
somehow don't know Andrew huberman and
you care about your well-being
um you know you should definitely listen
to them
I love you Andrew